Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Il professor Stephen Hawking
è stato un fisico di fama mondiale.
Tra le tante cose importanti
che ha detto e ha scritto,
una cosa che mi ha stupito
è stata una lettera aperta,
da lui pubblicata insieme
ad altri scienziati, nel 2015,
sui rischi, per il futuro dell'umanità,
dello sviluppo incontrollato
dell'intelligenza artificiale.
A me sembrava
una posizione un po' allarmista,
da un grande uomo di scienza,
e poi soprattutto da una persona
che era l'esempio vivente più chiaro
dei benefici dell'IA.
A lui consentiva di comunicare
col mondo esterno,
essendo affetto da una grave
malattia dei motoneuroni.
Dobbiamo dunque avere paura
dell'intelligenza artificiale?
Quali saranno gli impatti economici
e sociali di questa tecnologia?
Come modificherà il nostro modo
di essere, di vivere e di pensare?
Queste sono alcune delle domande
cui cerchiamo di dare una risposta,
qui al Centro Comune di Ricerca.
Per alcune questioni,
come l'impatto sociale ed economico,
non possiamo ancora dare una risposta,
perché sono fenomeni
che stanno giusto partendo adesso.
Per questo ci siamo dotati
di un Centro Europeo di Analisi
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
in modo da poter dare,
in tempi brevi, delle risposte informate.
Su altre questioni, però,
qualche idea ce l'abbiamo già
ed è di questo che voglio parlare.
Ma in prima analisi,
che cos'è l'Intelligenza Artificiale?
In realtà parliamo di sistemi
che noi diciamo intelligenti,
perché possono osservare il loro ambiente
e, sulla base di questo,
prendere delle decisioni o delle azioni
in modo abbastanza autonomo,
per arrivare a degli obiettivi prefissati.
Le applicazioni oggi più comuni
riguardano la robotica industriale,
il riconoscimento
di immagini, video, testo.
Noi già li usiamo normalmente
nei nostri telefoni cellulari,
o negli assistenti personali
come Alexa o Siri.
Non è che stiamo parlando
di qualcosa di totalmente nuovo.
In realtà sono tecniche statistiche
che hanno cominciato a svilupparsi
già dagli anni Cinquanta.
Quello che è successo, però,
negli ultimi sei, sette anni,
è che c’è stato, da un lato,
una crescita velocissima
della capacità di calcolo dei processori:
questi raddoppiano in potenza
ogni 18 - 24 mesi.
Ma soprattutto, c’è stato
uno sviluppo ancora superiore
dei dati in formato digitale.
Voglio darvi un esempio.
Quella che vedete
è un'immagine della British Library.
È una delle due biblioteche
più grandi al mondo.
Contiene più di 150 milioni
di oggetti in catalogo.
Si sviluppa su 14 piani,
e ha scaffali lunghi 600 kilometri,
come l'autostrada da Milano a Roma.
Adesso immaginatevi
milioni e milioni e milioni
di British Libraries,
una in cima all’altra.
Questo vi da l’idea del volume
di dati che viene creato ogni anno.
Con lo sviluppo
di miliardi di nuovi sensori,
addosso, in casa, in alto,
in ufficio, in strada,
tutti connessi tra di loro via Internet,
questo stesso volume di dati
verrà creato ogni giorno.
Questo vuol dire creare ogni giorno
tanti dati quanto nell'intera
storia dell'umanità.
È chiaro che noi, come umani,
non potremmo mai dare un senso
a questa mole di dati.
Per questo abbiamo bisogno,
sempre di più, di sistemi automatici,
che in qualche modo
filtrino tutti questi dati
e ne estraggano delle informazioni
che sono utili per noi.
Il tipo di sviluppo
che si sta avvicinando, già ora,
vedrà sempre di più
delle applicazioni utili,
soprattutto quelle in tempo reale.
Dalle automobili senza conducente
alla medicina a livello cellulare,
cioè diretta alla singola cellula malata,
o all'agricoltura di precisione,
dove quindi, passando
il trattore o il drone,
misura pianta per pianta
e addirittura foglia per foglia,
per vedere se ha bisogno
di un po' più d'acqua,
un po' più di pesticida,
un po' più di fertilizzante,
con un chiaro beneficio per l'ambiente
invece che spruzzare tutto
in modo indiscriminato.
Il fatto che noi si dipenda sempre di più
dall’intelligenza artificiale
per dare un senso a questa mole di dati,
vuol dire che c'è, già oggi,
una grossa competizione a livello globale.
Soprattutto tra Stati Uniti e Cina,
con due modelli di sviluppo diverso.
Negli Stati Uniti sono
le grosse società del web,
Google, Amazon, Microsoft, Apple,
che hanno preso la leadership.
Quindi il modello di sviluppo
è quello del profitto commerciale.
In Cina, è lo Stato
che ha un ruolo fondamentale,
sia per le linee di indirizzo,
sia per l'investimento in ricerca,
sia per l’allineamento
che è riuscito a creare
tra l'impresa pubblica, l'impresa privata
e anche le applicazioni militari.
Alla base di tutto questo
c’è il controllo dei dati.
In Cina, lo Stato ha, di diritto,
l'accesso ai dati personali
degli 800 milioni di utenti di Internet.
Per questo ha già oggi la leadership
nei software di riconoscimento facciale.
L'obiettivo dichiarato
è di poter riconoscere
ogni cittadino cinese,
un miliardo e 400 milioni di persone,
in meno di tre secondi.
Dare poi a ciascuno un punteggio
basato sia sul comportamento
nella vita fisica che su quella virtuale,
in modo tale che,
a base di questo punteggio,
vengano erogati o meno certi servizi.
Quindi, questo è una forma
di controllo sociale dello Stato.
Ma non è solo questo.
Per la Cina,
lo sviluppo dell'intelligenza artificiale
ha un valore strategico,
perché si tratta di passare
da uno sviluppo economico basato
sulla produzione di massa a basso costo
a una produzione invece
di alto valore aggiunto,
e di alto valore tecnologico.
Per questo, già oggi,
il 57% dei brevetti
sono registrati in Cina.
L'obiettivo della strategia cinese
è di essere leader mondiale per il 2030.
Dal lato loro, invece,
le multinazionali americane
rastrellano dati da tutto il mondo.
Basta pensare che l'80%
di tutte le ricerche su Internet
passa da Google.
Stiamo parlando di 70.000 al secondo.
Facebook ha 2,2 miliardi
di utenti al mese.
Facebook e Google, da soli,
hanno investito nel 2017
30 miliardi di dollari
in ricerca e sviluppo.
Questo è tre volte maggiore
del budget annuale di ricerca
dell'Unione Europea.
Investimenti, dati e ricerca
fanno sì che queste società
sappiano tutto di noi.
Conoscono i nostri gusti, le nostre spese,
dove abitiamo, dove lavoriamo,
chi sono i nostri amici.
E possono anche predire,
in modo molto accurato,
come faremo dopo.
Per cui vendono questi dati a terzi,
che poi ci offrono
dei servizi personalizzati,
ovvero ritagliano la loro offerta
sulla base di quella
che sanno essere la nostra domanda.
Ma il passo successivo è di modificare
la nostra domanda stessa.
Pertanto vedete che, regolarmente adesso,
vi viene raccomandato
in che albergo andare,
che ristorante andare,
che libro leggere, che musica ascoltare,
chi seguire - di chi fidarvi!
E adesso, di recente, avete visto
che vi dicono anche per chi votare.
Anche questa è una forma
di controllo sociale:
però da parte del Capitale,
invece che dello Stato.
E l’Europa, in tutto questo, che cosa fa?
L’Europa ha dei punti di forza:
ha una forte ricerca,
ha dei punti di leadership
nella robotica industriale,
in alcuni settori industriali
come l’automotive
e come, in generale, anche la medicina.
L’Europa sta cercando di trovare,
tra questi due modelli di sviluppo -
cinese e americano -
il suo modello,
basato soprattutto sull'etica
e sui principi fondativi
dell'Unione Europea,
ovvero i diritti dell'uomo
e i principi democratici.
Tutti i paesi dell'Unione
si rendono conto che,
da soli, non ce la faranno.
Per cui hanno già firmato
un protocollo politico di accordo,
per lavorare insieme allo sviluppo
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale,
proprio per non essere solo
una colonia digitale in balia di altri.
L'Unione Europea si è dotata,
a dicembre scorso,
anche di un progetto e un piano coordinato
di sviluppo per l'Intelligenza Artificiale
che ha l'ambizione di investire
20 miliardi di euro all'anno,
per dieci anni.
Proprio per fare sì che questa tecnologia
venga presa in tutti i settori economici,
che ci si prepari, da un punto
di vista sociale ed economico,
e anche per dotarsi
di un quadro etico e legale.
Anche noi al Centro Comune di Ricerca
abbiamo contribuito,
con un nostro studio, a questo piano
e abbiamo fatto anche delle proposte
che sono state recepite nel piano,
affinché lo sviluppo di questa tecnologia
offra delle opportunità per ridurre
le disuguaglianze sociali, non aumentarle.
Vi chiederete, però:
ma com’è che c'è così tanta attenzione
all’etica dell'Intelligenza Artificiale?
Ora, dovete sapere
che un gruppo di esperti ha già formulato
quelli che devono essere
i principi di base, ovvero:
l'intelligenza artificiale
dovrebbe agire per fare del bene;
evitare di fare del male
a individui, a gruppi o all'ambiente;
mantenere il controllo
e l'autonomia dell'individuo;
e anche essere giusta,
trasparente e non discriminatoria.
Molto bello.
Se però voi aprite il giornale,
o accendete la televisione di giorno,
mi sembra che di comportamenti etici,
in giro, non ne vedete così tanti.
Quindi, perché prestare
così tanta attenzione
ai principi etici
dell'intelligenza artificiale?
È perché noi sappiamo
che tecnologia e società lavorano insieme.
Noi costruiamo la tecnologia,
ma la tecnologia poi ci influenza.
E quindi, i valori
che noi poniamo nella tecnologia,
e scriviamo nel software,
sono i nostri valori.
Quindi dobbiamo stare bene attenti
a cosa ci mettiamo dentro.
Per tirare le fila:
l'intelligenza artificiale
offre grandi opportunità,
ma anche qualche rischio.
Il fatto che chi controlla questa
tecnologia, controlla il futuro,
e [che] alla base di tutto
sta il controllo dei dati,
vuol dire che tutti
dobbiamo renderci conto
e[d essere] più consapevoli
dell'importanza di dare valore
ai dati europei
per delle applicazioni europee.
E questa è, chiaramente,
una responsabilità di governo e industria,
ma anche di noi tutti come cittadini.
Dobbiamo essere più responsabili
dei nostri dati privati
e a chi diamo fiducia
affinché essi vengano trattati.
Il fatto che il futuro
non sia ancora definito,
che ci sia incertezza
sull'impatto economico
e sociale di questa tecnologia,
non ci deve spaventare.
Vuol dire che il futuro
non è ancora scritto.
Sta a noi tutti farlo.
Usando soprattutto la nostra,
di intelligenza.
Grazie.
(Applausi).